LAURIE: Welcome to
Photographers at Google.
And we're very pleased to have
Tamara Lackey with us today.
She is going to be
discussing embracing
self-consciousness, authentic
expression in portrait
photography.
Now she is a keynote speaker,
a fantastic photographer.
She's been on the Martha Stewart
Show, Extreme Makeover, Home
Edition, NBC's Today
Show, and she's also
been in many publications
including "O" magazine, "Men's
Journal," "Parenting"
magazine, and she's
the author of four books.
I got the pleasure of
interviewing her about a month
ago, and we are kindred
spirits, I would say.
I love her photography.
She actually photographs
children and portrait
photography, and
it's breathtaking.
We have different types
of photography that we do,
but I think we connected
because photography
is about capturing that moment,
and she does it so well.
And I'm so pleased to be able
to present Tamara Lackey.
Please give her a warm welcome.
TAMARA LACKEY:
Thank you very much.
That was very
verklempt, that intro.
Thank you.
And thank you, Laurie, for
putting all these talks
together.
For inviting me.
For all your work.
I really appreciate it.
And congratulations to all
of you for working here.
I just did a mini-tour
of the campus,
and we had an incredible lunch.
And, wow, what a
wonderful place to be.
I'm truly honored
to be invited here.
I have been shooting now
for more than 11 years,
professionally.
Obviously, I photographed
people a lot before that,
but they were horrible,
horrible pictures.
And in that time, I've shot
thousands of portraits.
And I've come to
realize that I wanted
to speak on this subject.
When Laurie said, what
do you want to speak on?
I kind of thought about
a lot of the topics
I do talk about, which has to do
with photography, and business,
and even work/life balance,
and the idea of how
you pull all this together.
But what stood out to
me, when I was looking
through a lot of
my favorite images,
is this idea, Embracing
Self-Consciousness.
Every single shoot I've
done, professionally--
and that's children, adults,
well-known celebrities,
athletes-- there's
been self-consciousness
that's been a part of it.
Every single one.
So how many people
here would say
that you recognize
that on your shoots?
I should actually wait.
How many people here
are photographers?
Most of you.
And how many people
have been in a situation
where you're either lifting the
camera or being photographed,
and you feel that sense
of self-consciousness?
Yes.
OK.
Good.
I'm in the right room.
And the reason that
stands out to me
is because, even though I
think all these other facets
of photography are so
important-- color balance,
proper exposure, metering,
foreground, background,
everything-- it's everything
about the entirety of the look
on someone's face that
matters to me the most.
And the reason
for that is that I
believe that expression is
the conduit to connection.
I think expression is the
conduit towards connection.
And feeling
disconnected, feeling
like you're not connecting
with other people, for me,
is one of the worst parts
of being a human being.
That feeling of aloneness.
Now when I talk
about being alone,
I don't mean having a cup
of tea and taking a bath,
and shutting the
door and saying,
everybody leave me alone.
That's an amazing feeling.
I mean the feeling
of aloneness you have
when you're in a
crowded room, and you
feel like you can't
communicate with other people.
You can't connect to them.
That you're not
feeling understood.
That's that feeling that's
the lack of connection.
And so I look for
expression because I
think it's that
conduit to connection.
So how do you find expression
that feels real and honest,
when you're photographing people
who are feeling self-conscious?
And you're bringing
self-consciousness
to the table.
How do you put someone at ease?
So to begin with,
when I'm talking
about self-consciousness,
let's discuss
the sensation a little bit.
Can anybody here give
a very good example
of the time they
felt self-conscious?
Come on.
AUDIENCE: Right now, or being
in front of [INAUDIBLE].
TAMARA LACKEY: When
you've been where I am?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And even-- and
also me, right now.
TAMARA LACKEY: Yes.
Or a time when you are going
for the job of your dreams.
Something that you
think would be amazing.
And you're standing
there in front
of the interviewer,
the person who
is going to make the
call on whether or not
you get that job of your dreams.
And for a moment, they're
just looking at you,
and they're evaluating you.
And you feel kind of
naked and exposed.
Hopefully not literally naked.
But exposed.
That feeling,
that's the sensation
of self-consciousness.
Or you're on a
date, and you feel
like, god, I've seen
a lot of people.
And this one, there's
something about them
that I feel like this
could really be something.
And if we could get past
this jangle of nerves
and awkwardness, this could
really be something significant
for the rest of my life.
But in that moment, where
it feels just uncomfortable,
that's the sensation
of self-consciousness.
Or when you've had a dozen
portraits taken yourself,
and they all are horrible.
They're terrible.
They don't represent you well.
You don't feel
like you look good.
You feel like you
spend a lot of time
online de-tagging yourself.
And you're sitting down to have
your portrait taken one more
time.
That feeling is
self-consciousness.
It's how do I appear?
How do I look?
How am I doing?
How am I coming across
in this situation?
So I believe that the job
of a portrait photographer
starts with making other
people feel at ease.
Actively trying to use
thoughts, feelings, and energy
to eliminating discomfort.
So how do you put
somebody at ease?
It depends on three factors.
One, who the person is.
Two, how long you
need them at ease.
This is the coolest
part of photography.
I'll get back to
that in a second.
And three, who you are.
So who the person is.
If you're dealing with
someone who just feels
a little bit uncomfortable, all
you need to bring to the table
is some calming energy to
slow the situation down,
some distraction
techniques, and you're good.
You do more than
that, and you're
going to make someone
feel more uncomfortable.
In a situation
like this, where I
have two brothers who are
very different individuals.
And I want to have them at ease
with each other and with me.
I know that I've got to
deal with a few things.
First and foremost,
I've got to deal
with a child who thinks
it's hilarious to never look
at the camera.
Has anybody
photographed this child?
I also need to deal with his
brother, who's not sure of me,
not sure of the
situation, and doesn't
want to be photographed
in the first place.
And before I can get this
moment here of the two of them
together, I have to set them up.
I've got to have a sharp
side of a reflector just out
of the frame on this
gray, rainy day,
shining just the perfect
amount of fill light on them.
I've got to set them in a
pose that I think starts
out a little stilted,
but then they
turn it into something that's
a lot more comfortable.
And I have to get them engaged
with each other and with me,
because I'm the one
holding the lens,
and once they're
comfortable with me,
they're going to be
comfortable-looking to anybody
who views this image later.
But I can't do any
of that if I have
them feeling uncomfortable.
So first and foremost,
I've got to figure out
how to get them at ease with me.
Another type of person
that you might photograph
is the person who
feels like they
know exactly what to do once
the camera is trained on them.
They're just going
to do their thing.
And you get this a lot, right?
That kind of cheese look.
That preconditioned response.
And that's why I
never say things
like, say cheese or smile.
Because I feel like people will
bring something that they think
works.
And if you just spend a
little bit of extra time,
employ some
distraction techniques,
you get something authentic.
And it's worth the wait.
But it often takes a
little bit of time.
Some good-natured prompting.
One of the things I try
never to do with my subjects
is use negative terminology.
I try to not ever say something
like, God, that is not working.
That does not look good.
Don't do that again.
We'll start with,
great, fantastic,
it's amazing what
you just did there.
Let's try this.
And then slowly, we
work our way through.
What else does it depend
on, putting someone at ease?
Depends on the amount of
time you need them at ease.
This, for me, is the
coolest part of photography.
All I ever need to
make a great photograph
is literally a
fraction of a second.
That's it.
I can create a great
collection of portraits
by having a fraction of a second
here and a fraction of a second
there.
And that's all I need.
And that takes so much
pressure off of me
when I get into
a situation where
I feel kind of
uncomfortable, or I
feel like it's going
to be a challenge,
and I don't know what to do.
So, to me, the idea of
taking all that pressure off
is fantastic.
Because the other individual
you'll come up against
is the one who is overwhelmed
by the energy of the situation,
or finds it torturous
to be photographed.
And if I just need one
second, one moment where
he can lift his eyes
towards me, and I
can get one shot where his
eyes are the widest they are,
I've done my job.
This was literally
that situation.
I'm in my studio.
This little boy
is a very nervous.
He won't look up at all.
I'm on the back wall
with my 7200 lens.
And I got one click.
It was this click, before
he went back down again.
And that's the cover
of my first book.
So to me, that's
a really big deal.
I only need one second.
That moment just after
the toddler has a tantrum
and just after he
falls over the dog,
you get that one shot
before you aid the child.
That's all I need.
By the way, no
animals or children
were harmed in the making
of this photograph.
I think that when you give
it that extra second, when
you realize I don't need this
to be a great experience all
the way through, if you watch
sometimes, my shoots on video,
it kind of looks like,
is she getting anything?
I know I'm getting things here
and there, but on the whole,
it may not look like that.
You only need a
hair-breadth of a second
to get something
richer than what
they are giving you before.
And it may not last long.
Which brings me
to my next point.
These images don't need to be
full of laughter and joyful.
And they don't
need to be smiles.
And they don't even need
to be dramatic or powerful.
They may not last very long,
and you need to be ready.
This is where the technical
proficiency of the photographer
comes into place.
I always make sure I
have everything set up
before I even think
about expression.
And that means I
have the lighting,
I have the composition,
I've got the framing.
I know that in any given moment,
I might get what I want to get.
I get all the
little details done
in terms of face-leaking,
snot, the things that
happen with children.
I make sure all of that is
taken care of, so at the moment
the shot happens, the expression
is there, and I get it.
I'm happy.
But otherwise, the
amount of times
that I'll witness in workshops
or mentoring sessions, where
I'll watch a photographer
and something unbelievable
has unfolded, and they don't
have a camera even near them,
or it's down hanging
around their neck.
I'm always holding it up here.
We'll share a bit
of that in a second.
The last part, the question of
how you put someone at ease.
It depends on who you are.
I strongly suggest
that anybody here
who's a portrait photographer
or wants to become a better
portrait photographer spend
some serious time trying
to figure out what's
going on in your own head.
I think we'll get to
that a little bit more,
about self-awareness.
But these are the factors
I care about the most, when
it comes to putting
someone at ease.
Who the person is, the amount
of time I need them to ease,
and what I'm bringing
to the table.
What I can help my
subject transcend,
or what I can worsen, if
I'm not paying attention.
When I have the chance
to photograph President
Obama, who's not a child,
I had the experience
of being with
someone who was very
comfortable in every situation.
That's part of what
you'll find sometimes.
That someone who already brings
great expression to the table,
because they're already very
comfortable with who they are.
I had, I think, 1/125
of a second with him.
And I had a speed light bounced
off the wall next to us.
And I'm shooting this at a 4/5.
In this rare case, the
subject was significantly less
self-conscious than I was.
When I'm photographing two women
that I found very impressive,
Michelle Obama and
Maya Angelou, I
had about five minutes of time.
And I'm sitting
there photographing
one woman I greatly admire, and
another woman whose poetry I'd
been gobbling up
since my childhood.
The woman who wrote, "When
someone shows you who they are,
believe them the first time."
And she also wrote, "I'm
grateful to be a woman.
I must have done something
great in another life."
I like that.
Oh.
Lots of men in the room.
Just noticed that.
So I see these two women
looking back at me,
and I recognize that
the only person who
is going to screw
this shot up is me.
Because they are composed.
They look beautiful.
Again, I have a
speed light on this.
I'm shooting at ISO 800, 1/125
of a second, 3/5 aperture.
Everything is kind of set up.
And the only thing
that's going to go wrong
is if I can't stay natural
and engaging with them.
When I'm photographing Hillary
Clinton, this was about,
I think, 10 minutes of time
that I had alone with her.
And she'd just left
a press pit, where
she'd been smiling
for quite some time.
And if you've ever
photographed somebody
who's done the smile
for a very long time,
it's really hard to
get them refreshed
and get that smile
back in their eyes.
No matter how well-trained
they are at facing a camera.
And it wasn't-- I think I had
about eight or nine frames that
I took.
And it wasn't until
this very last one
where that smile finally
got back into the eyes.
It's not always a
home run that you're
going to capture a very natural
expression with someone who's
very comfortable
with themselves.
There's all the other
factors of how they're doing.
But at the end of
the day, it was
me who needed to get
comfortable in this situation
and bring some ease back to her.
The reason I feel like it's very
important to manage yourself
in these situations is
one of my favorite quotes,
"It's hard to fight an enemy
who has outposts in your head."
For us, as portrait
photographers,
our nerves, our
awkwardness, our temptation
to get lost in the technical
details of what's going on,
can help us miss the subject
that's right in front of us
and leave them
feeling very alone.
I think these issues are the
little outposts in our head,
as portrait photographers.
All that being said,
most of the time,
I'm the one managing the
fears, and the awkwardness,
and the pure discontent
of some of my subjects.
He doesn't want to be here.
He doesn't want me to be there.
But, to me, this is a successful
image because it's real,
it's authentic.
It doesn't have to be the
perfect smile every time.
It just has to be real.
Most of us would recognize
a huge difference
between this image-- this is a
pained, strained, sweet, sweet
effort of a nine-year-old boy.
And this image, where it's
relaxed and comfortable.
What would you say, outside
of the obvious, one looks
like an uncomfortable
smile and one doesn't, what
would you say is the difference
here between these two images?
One person who's comfortable.
AUDIENCE: The second one
is a neutral posture.
TAMARA LACKEY: The second one
has a more neutral posture.
Yep.
And his body feels more relaxed.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Distance
from the subject.
TAMARA LACKEY: Distance
to subject, yes.
So the two major things there.
One, he was so aware
of the lens that it
was breaking any ability
for him to be comfortable.
So what I had to do was pull
the lens away from my face,
step backwards, switch to--
actually, in this case,
I switched angles and lenses.
And that's actually one of
the techniques I employ often.
I switch my distance
to subject and lenses
as much to manage things
like perspective distortion
or focal length as I do to
give my subjects space from me.
To give them a break from me.
And sometimes I
find I have to do it
the other way, where
I need to get closer.
That they want more nearness
to feel more comfortable.
But that is something
I often think
about when I'm
choosing my equipment.
It's not just, what will
this do for me technically,
but how will this be able
to engage my subject better.
I think one of the biggest
bonuses of being a portrait
photographer that
I have found is
that we are training
ourselves to find
more beauty in our subjects.
And that means the
angle the head,
the way they're lit, all
that sort of thing, sure.
But it also has to
do with how do you
make someone look their best?
How do you make them
shine and feel more lively
and seem more engaged?
And how do you interact in
a way that brings them out?
To me, it's kind of difficult
to think that you do that,
but pretty much stop once
you put the camera down.
Like it's like the job's
over because you've
lowered the lens.
I think that you've
trained yourself not only
to see people's better
angles, but their better
moments in the
rest of your life.
And that's been just
such a huge perk,
for me as a portrait
photographer,
that that skill doesn't go
away because we lower the lens.
You start to recognize that
people's self-consciousness
appear in all kinds of ways.
Appear as like awkwardness,
and sometimes cattiness,
even cruelty,
silence over talking.
And the odd amount
of ways we clumsily
navigate our own
feelings, when people
are paying a lot of attention
to us, and we feel off.
This question, so what
do you want from me?
Is pretty much what most
people ask when you lift a lens
and you point it at their face.
They may not say that out loud.
Although some people
literally will be like,
what do you want from me?
Most of the time,
they don't say that.
That pained, strained
expression on that boy's face,
that's what he's asking.
What do you want from me?
How does this go?
What do I do now?
Even well-trained,
professional models,
who have been perfectly trained
on how to pose, and look,
and turn this and that
way, don't necessarily
have what it takes to
bring warmth and engagement
and spirit to a shoot.
I recently had a great
time down in Puerto Rico.
I was able to bring my whole
family, which was wonderful.
This was about six
or seven weeks ago.
Photographing this
professional model
for a spa and cosmetics company.
And there were about
10 of us all together.
I think we came from about
four different states.
Down to Puerto Rico.
Specifically chose that
location for the waterfall.
They have a product company
that deals with fresh waters
and healing waters,
and they wanted
to have this kind of
look for the campaign.
So we all come down
from all these places,
and we hike two miles down from
the rain forest, El Yunque.
And we hit these waterfalls.
And it's the model, myself, the
client, all my gear, the outfit
changes, our assistants,
stylists, etc.
We all get down to the
spot, we start shooting.
We've got a beautiful woman.
We've got beautiful posing,
a beautiful location.
And what we're starting out
with is this kind of look.
This kind of look.
This trained model.
And she's beautiful.
But what she's giving us is
these kind of fill-in-the-blank
expressions.
The look that she's
been trained to give.
What my client wanted was
warm, welcoming, friendly,
approachable.
And we were having a
big disconnect right out
of the gate.
Not just right out of the gate.
Quite a ways into the shoot.
Where she looked lovely,
the location looked lovely,
but it was missing the
whole feel of all the ad
words in their campaign.
So what we had to do was
move from sexy to soft.
From this fill-in-the-blank to
sweet, warm, and approachable.
And what I found while
I was shooting her,
all the thought I have about
self-consciousness when
it comes to people who
aren't trained to be models
is that self-consciousness
doesn't always
look like self-consciousness.
So we stopped, and we took
a break, and we rehearsed.
We slowed down, and
we kept emptying her
of these empty looks.
If that makes sense.
Literally, no, no.
Stop.
Too sexy.
Stop it.
Breathe.
Let's start again.
And what she found was
that warm and approachable
requires her to dig a lot
deeper than this steely kind
of open jaw look.
And we got to it.
We got smile.
We got welcoming.
We got warmth.
She laughed, and we all
genuinely enjoyed the shoot.
And my client was thrilled with
the images we were getting.
We ended up getting a
lot of natural looks.
Enough to meet the entire
campaign for the year.
But it didn't
start out that way.
It didn't start
anything like natural,
when all we were
going for was natural.
Self-consciousness
doesn't always
look like self-consciousness.
So we know what it feels
like, that sensation
that we talked about,
self-consciousness.
And we know what
it can look like,
the various ways it shows up.
But what exactly is
self-consciousness?
We start out baby, toddler-hood
finally recognizing
that the person in the
mirror is actually--
thanks for staying--
the person in the mirror
is actually not someone
perfectly mimicking us.
It takes a while
to figure that out.
That this is actually ourselves.
That we're a stand-alone
thing in the world.
We stand apart.
We can actually see
ourselves reflected back
at this very early age.
That standalone thing, I
think, is pretty fascinating.
Because back to the
beginning of my talk,
I talk about what I think is
one of the worst parts of being
human, that feeling of standing
apart, and standing alone,
and feeling like
you can't connect.
The reason why I
think expression
is so vastly important.
This idea of self-consciousness
starts very early
as just a recognition.
But as we move into it, as
babies, that same question of,
what do you want from me
starts out with, who are you
and why are you here?
And to be able to work through
the self-consciousness that
even comes at this age means
putting someone at ease.
One of the techniques
I use often,
if you look right here with the
camera and my face, is I hardly
ever have it up
to my eyes when I
know I'm working with a young
child, because all I'll do
is block connection.
I frequently am here,
here, here, here, and over.
And this works wonders with
having someone look back
at you, and look very
friendly and engaged.
The other thing I do often is
I hold my camera down here.
Even when I'm not shooting,
it's at the ready.
And I'll pull it up
in just a second.
But a lot of my
shoots are like this.
So with children this age,
their self-consciousness
is more focused on understanding
that technically they
stand apart, and they know
that their image is actually
themselves, but they're
not interested in getting
their image photographed.
That's why containment
is so important.
Looking at this pose,
what do you see here?
This pose, what is one of the
main things you see mom doing?
Containing the child.
Look at all the ways, too.
We've got both legs pulled back.
We've got the belly pulled in.
We literally have the elbow
pulling the shoulder back.
This is a pure
containment thing.
And the only reason
mom's got her legs
crossed is so we can mirror
it, and make it look more
like a pose and
less like a jailing.
That's it.
The other reason we have
mom's legs pulled back,
and I think about
this a lot, is I'm
shooting from a
lower angle, and I'm
shooting with a wider
lens-- I think in this case
I'm shooting with probably a
24 millimeter focal length--
and because I'm right down, if
her legs are out in any way,
they look huge.
Because they're right
up against the lens.
So I'm constantly
having, depending
on the angle I'm shooting
from, making sure
that people tuck legs
and lean back and such.
Another great example, we have
this one and two-year-old boy
in my studio.
They're brothers.
They're extraordinarily grumpy.
They don't want to be there.
Mom really wanted to have
the session in a studio,
so we did that.
But I'm using another device
to basically contain them.
In this case, it's these two
four-by-eight foam boards,
these art boards, that are
taped together, normally
to reflect light
back on my subjects.
Here, we've turned them into
interplanetary, alien-operated
trapping devices.
And Dad is managing the hatch.
And whereas before, we
were getting really grumpy,
didn't want to be
there, didn't want
to stand there, just really
flat expressions, now they're
completely off the
studio backdrop.
I've pulled the soft box over
into our trapping device,
and as Dad let each one of
them run out and run free,
I'm getting this expression from
them as they're running out.
The change in the set,
the change in the game,
the change in mood
changed everything
about their expressions.
Another great technique
I use for containment
is physically kicking
my subjects back
into place underneath me.
It's not as violent
as it sounds.
I actually shared this image
with Laurie for our Women
in Google Photography Series.
But that's what I'm
doing with these.
I'm shooting directly over them.
I'm literally taking each
leg and kicking them back.
And I'm shooting with
a 35 millimeter lens.
And they find it hilarious
that some stranger
is kicking them, which is how
I get the expressions I get.
We moved from that
into this next stage.
Ages four through eight--
four, five, six, seven, eight,
sometimes nine.
This stage is huge.
And if you ever were a
child, if you know a child,
if you have a child,
you know this stage,
which is all about watch me.
This is when you're at
the pool, and someone's
going to go up the
diving board, and it
doesn't count unless
someone's watching.
Right?
Or across the monkey bars,
and you hear watch, watch,
watch, watch, watch.
This is the "watch me" stage.
And even the very
shy, reserved child
has elements of this in their
personality at this age.
It's very natural.
So this idea of putting
on a show, pulling out
poses, pulling out ideas,
they want to show you,
and they want to see
what it looks like.
We have the back of
the camera trained
kind of mentality going on.
So it's watch me,
notice me, look at me.
And my subjects are
forming themselves
into something worth watching.
That's what they're doing.
They think, I'm going to
put something together
that's worth watching.
And that's what I get
a lot of at this age.
One of the things that's
fantastic about that is you
get this amazing engagement
if you play along.
And you go ahead and you
goad them, and say, OK.
Well, can you do this?
Show me if you can do this.
And I find myself
saying things like, I'll
lay flat on the ground.
Jump right over me.
Try not to kick my head.
Sometimes they do,
sometimes they don't.
This is a perfect
example of another time
like, if you reach me before I
leave, you can knock me over.
And you can knock me over hard.
That's the shot I got.
Again, 35, 1/4 lens right
before I did get knocked down.
In desperate situations,
I'll say if you can catch me,
you can put leaves in my
hair or sand in my hair.
Or anything that's nearby.
This is a perfect
example of that.
He reached me.
I got the great shot I
wanted right beforehand.
And these like dried-out,
clean leaves, these were awful.
These don't come out after
one, two, three showers.
They're just in there.
But basically what
they're saying
is watch me be something
worth watching.
That's what this
whole age is about.
There's a lot of
people who probably
argue that social media
extends this stage for us.
For quite some time.
But that's the discussion
for another platform.
And either way, it's often
very present at the stage.
So engagement's funny.
Watch me do something.
That's funny.
How do you move
past that to create
stronger portraits at this age?
So you get this.
You get the watch me do
something sort of thing.
Then you find out
who they are and what
particular distractions
will work for them.
And it's different
for everybody.
Some people are very
interested in things
that peak their curiosity.
Some people are interested
in facts, and details,
and numbers, and saying
something rapidly in Spanish.
Some people are
interested in you,
if you can be
interesting enough.
You move beyond that, and
then you bring in humor.
And you get that natural smile
that you wanted all along,
but you kind of
have to start there.
This is a really
natural pattern for me.
It comes up time and time again.
The idea of, what
do you want from me?
Let's be silly.
Let's respond in a fun way.
And then the authentic look.
Even really shy children--
I keep going back to this
because I feel like
the whole stage sounds
like all these kids are
playing and racing around,
and we all know children
who don't do that.
They're quieter, they're
softer, they're more reserved.
So even the shy child who
shows more vulnerability,
they're still wondering
that same sort of question.
What is it that
you want from me?
What am I supposed to do?
And there's some beauty
in that delicate look.
There's so much beauty in that.
If I want to elicit
the very shy smile,
I may get it for that fraction
of a second we talked about.
How long you need it.
And this is another
great example
of a time where I'm holding
the camera over here,
and she's looking at me.
The way she is looking
is at me, at my face,
but the camera's all
the way over here.
And all I'm doing is
ensuring that I'm setting up
the composition so that her
eyes skim across the frame.
So it's a more natural
framing of the subject.
But I have this sweet look
that I get, and it doesn't
last long, but
that's all I need.
This is another
time where I'm doing
the exact same sort of thing.
I'm actually running with
her, through the leaves,
and the camera is at my waist.
Completely at my waist.
Her expression,
she's looking at me.
Her eyes are meeting my eyes.
I'm taller than her.
And I'm shooting,
and I'm maxing--
this is later in the day,
so the light's dropping,
so I'm maxing my ISO.
Something like a
5,000, I think is
what I've got, on a Nikon D4.
Thank you for making
those ISO capabilities.
The sensitivity
of ISO in cameras
has allowed me so
much more flexibility
with fast-moving subjects,
because now I can constantly
pop my shutter speed up
without additive light.
It's fantastic.
So I think I'm at about a
5,000 ISO and a 5/0 aperture,
because I want to keep her
in focus as we're moving.
I'm shooting this with
the 24/70/28 lens, which
is the lens I always grab when
I'm on the move with children.
And I want to keep up with her.
And I want that playfulness.
And I want that kind of
performance and that silliness.
And this is a lot of how I get
it when I'm with my subjects,
is I make sure the
camera is the least
apparent part of the shoot.
I'm aware that these children
are aware of the lenses,
and I try to slowly eliminate
it in every way I can.
So we've got a
lot of engagement,
a lot of playfulness, this
again is part of every shoot.
Another thing I really
like is the quiet part.
The simple part.
The slow it down.
After enough of that
rush of engagement,
this becomes kind of a welcome
relief when you're actually
delivering a
collection of images.
Every session I do is probably
about 60 images I turn around.
And they're all this kind
of spectrum of expression,
a lot going on, a
lot of activities.
But there's always
this quiet part.
It's kind of when you watch a
movie, and you get to the part
where it slows down
and lets you catch up.
Or you're reading a book, and
you can take a deep breath.
That's what I think of when
I capture these images.
I'm trying to find these.
So the way I'm
able to do this is
I become exceptionally boring.
On purpose.
And probably in real life.
But the idea of becoming
background noise.
Becoming the hum
in the restaurant
while other people talk
about something more
interesting above it.
You do that by wearing them out,
by playing at the max level,
and they eventually want to move
away from you for a little bit.
I photographed this portrait in
Clearwater Beach a month ago.
I think 3 and 1/2 weeks ago.
And I was playing with
two children, two girls
and their mom.
And we were in the sand,
and we were rolling around,
and we were literally in the
waves, this close to losing
my phone again in the ocean.
And I'm shooting this.
I step back because the energy
is kind of calming down.
And they just ignore me.
And they're just silencing
down a little bit.
I shot this with spot
metering, because I'm
shooting into the sun.
This is an F9.
That's how I keep
the detail in the sky
is the aperture and
the metering option.
I don't need any fill
light on this shot,
because I've got a very
small subject who's
got this huge bounce of light on
this bright, bright sand coming
right back up at her.
One of the reasons I do love
beach photography quite a lot,
I can bring a lot
less equipment.
If you've ever held a reflector
on the beach with the wind,
you become a kite.
So I don't need that
on days like this.
And this idea of bringing
this in is so important to me.
Another image from around
the same time, this dreamier
expression.
Part of why I think these are
really powerful to capture
is we go back to the idea of
embracing self-consciousness.
When these moments happen,
when people zone out,
when they get dreamy, they're
not feeling self-conscious,
are they?
You kind of let that go.
Have you ever done that,
where you're just zoning out?
And like your brain goes
to sleep for a second,
and your eyes go to
sleep for a second,
and then somebody's
like [SNAPPING].
It's like stop it.
That felt so good.
That moment of being able
to just kind of power
down a little bit.
When I see that
in my subjects, I
find that so alluring
because it just
seems like we get so much
less of that in the world.
This is another perfect
image of the same girl.
This is about two seconds later.
Back up with focus and delight.
I'm actually shooting this
from inside the bushes,
peeking through the
bushes with my long lens.
And she finds that so dorky.
And that's the shot I get.
But this age, this age
between four and nine,
this is most of the
area I focus my work on.
Is this age of child.
And I work with a
lot of photographers
who photograph only adults
and say, why do you do it?
Why would you want to
bring all your gear
and chase some kid who's
snotting everywhere?
Who won't listen to you?
What do you want to
even do that for?
For me, I find that
I'm extraordinarily
drawn to this kind of age
group, and beyond actually.
But it does seem to
be a lot of my focus.
Because self-consciousness at
this age is so malleable still.
They're still very open.
They understand that they
stand apart in the world.
can perform and do something.
They're having ideas
of who they are.
But they also are really open
to anything you say, too.
You'll say, I'm beautiful.
And they'll say, yeah, totally.
Like, of course.
Like, why wouldn't I be?
I don't think I've ever,
ever flipped the camera over
and shown a five, six,
seven-year-old girl
her picture, and she said, oh,
I look-- all the bad words,
right?
Ugly, this, blah, blah.
No.
I look great.
That's hilarious.
What a good jump I did.
And that's it.
That's as far as it goes.
To me, there's something
so refreshing about that.
It's so easy.
And I love the idea
of thinking that we
could do that with adults.
That you could photograph.
I'm trying to think if I've
ever photographed an adult
and shown them the back of the
camera, and they haven't said,
oh, that one thing
on my one thing.
Like, whatever it is.
The amount of people
walking around
who are convinced that they
have eyes too close together,
legs too short, one arm's
longer than the other.
I don't know.
It astounds me.
It really does.
We absorb so much negative
information about ourselves
from others, or our perception
of ourselves in the mirror.
And the beautiful
beauty industry.
This how do I look idea
is so easy at that age.
But it starts getting tougher
as children get older.
Ages nine, 10, 11, 12, 13.
Suddenly the question of
watch me, how did it look?
Becomes how do I look?
Like, literally, how do I look?
And for the first time
ever, at this age,
children start wondering,
am I presenting
the image I want of
myself to others?
Isn't that crazy?
That never before in
their self-consciousness
has that come up.
You've never seen that.
And suddenly it becomes a thing.
How did I look?
Did I look pretty?
Did I look cool?
Did I look fashionable?
Did I look sporty?
Am I someone that others
will find popular?
If you put this on Instagram,
how many likes will I get?
What will this mean?
Is this the image I want
to present to others?
And suddenly you start
taking these images
and self-consciousness
becomes so much more raw.
There's so much more
vulnerability now.
It reminds me a lot of
walking through and learning
a lot about Google.
When you build technology,
it works really well up
until a certain point.
Right?
You reach a capacity threshold,
a certain number of hits.
Something happens, and
you need to re-tool
it to make it work
again at this new level.
Correct?
With human beings,
it's the same way.
The same techniques that
work and work and work just
stop right about when
you hit this age.
So now you have to
find a way to work
with these new sensibilities,
these new raw feelings,
these new questions.
And you have to
ask yourself, how
do I, as a portrait
photographer who
is really interested in
getting a real, authentic image
of this person, how do
I make them feel sure
when they're starting
to feel so unsure?
How do I meet this new
level of self-consciousness?
First and foremost, it
helps to recognize it.
You look at an image like
this, and she's smiling.
And she looks pretty.
And she's not making that
kind of painful grin any more.
She's not looking
at me like she's
strained or uncomfortable.
Right?
Seems like it's a
nice sort of smile.
But you realize when you look
at it a little bit more, well,
there's certainly no real
smile around the eyes.
Yes, we've got catch
lights, and that helps.
But there's no real
crinkle around the eyes.
And she's got a tightness
around her jaw, right?
This is her real smile, by
the way, is what she tells me.
She's got a tightness
around the jaw.
And the way she's holding
herself completely straight
up and down doesn't indicate
much in the way of engagement.
You compare that to a couple
seconds later, a few more bits
of conversation, a little
bit more distraction.
Same sort of smile, but
now it's reached her eyes.
And you can see that in
the way they're positioned.
Just the way that they
crinkle up just a bit.
You've got a lot more
softness around the jaw.
Do you see the difference
in the jaw line?
And the smile?
We've got the natural
tilt of the head, which
you see all the time when
people actually engage.
The difference between
this and like I'm
actually welcoming
and interested in you.
It's just a hair-breadth apart,
but it's massively different.
It makes a big, big difference.
It's interesting.
I was recently filmed by Nikon.
They came down to North
Carolina, where I'm from.
And they did five
different shoots
of me photographing portraits.
And right before they
came, they sent me a clip
that they'd just done with this
great adventurer photographer.
And they showed me one of
the series they did with him.
And I'm looking at
this beautiful film.
They did such a
great job with it.
And they're up on this mountain.
It's these mountain vistas.
And there's a rock climber.
And he's like hanging
off the mountain,
and there's this gorgeous sun.
And it's just this
huge, beautiful scene.
As I'm watching
this, it struck me
that I wanted to make sure I
communicated to the producer
that in so many ways,
we're kind of going
to be doing the same
thing with my shoot.
It's just the canvas is
now right on the face.
And the body.
And the tension that one
holds or doesn't hold.
And it's still so beautiful,
and it's still so dramatic,
but it's going to be different.
But I want people to
know that between right
there, the forehead, and
right there, the chin,
there are all these
intricate details.
And if you tune in, you pay
attention, you really feel it,
and you don't accept
the image on the left.
You say, that's fine, but we're
going to keep going for a while
so we get something more real.
After that, you
start moving along.
And suddenly it's like you've
been able to build a bridge
where someone's not
trying at all anymore.
They feel very comfortable.
Again, you have to move
past lens awareness,
where they're so
conscious of the lens,
to the fact where they're
just engaging with you.
It takes a while,
but it's always
worth the work of doing so.
So self-consciousness, of
course, ages well past this.
Many people have probably
their own personal stories
of what their own
self-consciousness turns into.
But we have all this feeding
into us in terms of how I look.
We see more and more
pictures every day.
We have more negative
information every day.
And we end up learning more
negative things about ourselves
than we've ever heard before.
I read this the other day.
At any day of your life, you
now know more negative things
about yourself than you ever
did in your whole life before.
Kind of crazy to think
about it that way.
And really, really depressing.
So what agreements do you make?
Anybody here ever read "The Four
Agreements" by Don Miguel Ruiz?
Part of it?
A very simple, easy read.
And without going into
detail on the book,
I want to share
with you a take-away
I got from it that has given
me a huge advantage in portrait
photography.
And I'd love for
you to have it, too,
if you're going to be
photographing people.
The take-away from
the book, and I'm
totally, totally
paraphrasing this
based on how I perceived
it and how I applied it.
So someone might read
the book and say,
what are you talking about?
But this is the
take-away I got from it.
Is that you have the choice
to agree, each and every time,
with anything that's ever
being said about you.
And if that sounds overly
simplistic, let me explain.
If you were told once, when
you were a teenager, that you
should never smile in pictures
because it didn't look good,
you have the opportunity
right there at that moment
whether you agree or not.
And that changes
everything about the way
you may or may not
smile for pictures
for the rest of your life.
That idea that you can agree.
Or if you were told
by a friend that you
don't look good in red.
You have an opportunity
right there,
whether or not
you want to agree.
If you were told by a coach
that you weren't good enough
for varsity, you could choose to
go on and have Michael Jordan's
career.
Because he was cut
from his varsity team.
Or you could sit there
and agree and be done.
If a crowd of
publishers told you
that your book wasn't
worth publishing,
you could still be JK Rowling.
So you always have this chance
to agree or not to agree.
Why this matters to me
with portrait photography
is that I have so
many of my subjects,
my adult subjects
especially, but really
over that age of nine,
10, who have come in
with these agreements
that they have already
made with every negative
thing they've ever
heard about themselves.
They've already come in and
decided that this is true.
And what I'm saying is
you look at that person,
and I'm going to have a
totally different agreement.
I've already agreed
that everybody
who comes and sits down is
ridiculously good-looking.
They're seriously,
seriously attractive.
And by having that
one small shift,
by knowing that it's
already there, and all
I have to do is use lighting,
the right equipment,
good posing, to show
what I already see.
It makes all the
difference in the world.
It truly does.
By coming in and
saying, I have already
agreed that you are
seriously good-looking.
And we're going to
start from there.
And good-looking is a
fun term to say anything
in the way of just beautiful.
I just need to show that.
My friend, Barb.
I had the opportunity to
photograph her in the hospital.
Again with this huge advantage,
as a portrait photographer,
of knowing that
she is beautiful.
She was born with a condition,
an auto-immune disease,
that basically gave her
sever muscle weakness.
And her whole life,
she couldn't even
speak throughout her whole
childhood, it was so severe.
And in her '40s, was
diagnosed with breast cancer.
And as she's going
through, this was
being checked into
the hospital for
a radical double mastectomy.
And as she is going
through chemo,
a really crazy thing happened.
Which was, her
symptoms that she'd
had her whole life with
this auto-immune disease
started lessening and
lessening and lessening.
Because the auto-immune
disease attacked her body
when she was in
better health, and it
lessened when she
was in worse health.
And so when she was in what
many people would think
the most unfair, cruel situation
possible, she was at more peace
than she'd ever been
in her whole life.
I'm coming in as a photographer.
And I am starting
out with saying,
OK, you're already beautiful.
But you honestly
look more beautiful
than I've ever seen you before.
Right now, as I'm
sitting across from you.
All I have to do, all
my job is right now,
is to light this, pose
this, and shoot this.
And that's it.
Because I've started out
with this first part.
This first agreement.
And people just keep
proving me right,
when I start from that place.
Which makes my job a lot easier.
I don't even have to-- there's
a great example of most
of the time, when I'm
photographing children
of this age, all they want to
do is get as far away from me
as possible.
They want to be anywhere
that my lens is not.
I don't have to
agree with them when
they don't want to
be photographed.
I've already agreed that they're
going to get photographed.
That's how important that kind
of agreement is in my job.
So all I need to do is capture
them, contain them, and shoot
them.
So self-consciousness.
We've talked a lot
about that subject,
all the different forms.
How is that different
than self-awareness?
And why does that
matter in photography?
Self-consciousness
and self-awareness
are actually the same thing.
Psychologists say these
are the same exact thing.
Self-awareness is just
self-consciousness
taken to the next level.
Where you see more
than just yourself,
you see your place in the world
from an overall perspective.
And I would argue you have a
lot more humor about yourself
and the rest of the world.
But the way we address
self-consciousness
and self-awareness
as a society is we
think of self-consciousness
as a weakness.
It's an adjective we use to
negatively describe somebody.
We'd say things like, oh my
god, she's so self-conscious.
That's like a negative thing.
But about somebody
who's very self-aware,
we'd say, oh, he's very
self-aware, very enlightened.
This is a compliment.
This is a positive.
When in fact, it's
kind of the same thing.
How it differs in
photography is this.
When you think about a
celebrated war photographer,
how often do you think one would
see some heart-wrenching scene
and not lift his
camera because he's
afraid of how he might be
looking as he photographs them?
It doesn't happen.
When you're that good,
you get past that level
of self-consciousness.
Self-awareness is
not stepping in front
of the guy with the gun
to get a better shot.
That's kind of a difference.
To put it in everyday terms,
as a wedding photography,
self-consciousness
might be standing
in front of a group
of 100 people,
and all eyes are on you,
and you're directing them.
Getting past self-consciousness
allows you to do that.
Getting past
self-consciousness and not
practicing self-awareness
means you walk up
to the front of the church
in the middle of the ceremony
and you throw an
iPad at the couple,
and you photograph
the most sacred part
of the whole experience.
Which I don't know if you
guys have been to any weddings
recently, but I've
actually seen that.
That's getting past
self-consciousness
and not practicing
self-awareness.
Where self-awareness helps
you in portrait photography
is back to having that
kind of sense of humor
about the whole thing.
Like, at the end of the
day, seriously, it's OK.
This image, I
photographed in my studio.
And again, I have
everything set up
before I even think about taking
the shot or the expression.
So the lighting's in place.
We had soft box as a main light.
A constant soft box.
We had a fill light on the side.
And my exposure was set.
I think it was at ISO 1,000.
I'm at 1/500th of a second.
And I'm shooting within a
Nikon D4, and the 85 1/4 lens.
So everything's all set,
and all we're going to do
is add a little bit of
wind with the intention
of having her hair
blow back a little bit.
And this happened the
second we turn on the fan.
Now there's two ways
to go about this.
One is to think, the shot got
ruined, let me fix her hair.
And let me start again.
The other is to say,
this is the shot.
Based on your idea of
humor and self-awareness
and your level of
self-consciousness
you're bringing in.
I've actually shown
this to people
who said, oh, it didn't
work out, did it?
What do you mean?
I think it's
absolutely charming.
It depends on how you view it.
I think of this as an endearing
image, not an imperfection.
So my good friend, King
Solomon, said this.
"In all thy getting,
get understanding."
To me, I think
starting with yourself,
getting a better
idea of what you're
bringing to the table in
portrait photography, is huge.
If there's anything that most
limits you from freeing others
from their
self-consciousness, it's
you being trapped in yours.
I'll say that again.
If there's anything that most
limits you from freeing others
from their
self-consciousness, it's
you being trapped in yours.
If you can't stand in
the middle of a shoot
and completely forget
about yourself, and just
do whatever it takes.
Go ahead, kick me in
the head, spit on me,
let me roll on the
ground with you.
Hopefully I'm talking
about children.
But however you need
to photograph adults.
If you can't do
this, you're going
to miss an opportunity to get
some real dynamic expression.
We have some time for Q&A. Yes?
AUDIENCE: So all you need
is that 1/25 of a second
to capture that
right expression,
but can you actually.
Like, I agree, but I never
see that 1/25 of a second.
Like it comes and
it goes, and I never
know if I've got it
until I get home,
and I look through all
my 200 photographs.
So are you able to do that?
TAMARA LACKEY: While
that moment's happening?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do
you have a good time
and know that you've got it?
And what advice do you give
people who aren't getting it?
TAMARA LACKEY: No.
That's a wonderful question.
So the question is, how do
you know that you've got it?
Do you see it on the spot?
One of the things I try to do
is get all the technical stuff
done, just done.
So I don't have to
pay attention to that.
So I could be solely,
obsessively, ridiculously
focused on my subject.
And so I'm going to be,
if I'm photographing you,
I'm looking at every
nuance on your face
to the point where you're
probably way uncomfortable.
But then you're going to
laugh out of discomfort.
And I'm going to get a wonderful
1/125 of a second shot of you.
And that is a lot of it.
So because I'm not really
worried about how I sound
or what I'm doing or what I look
like, I'm just focusing on you.
AUDIENCE: I mean are you
firing at 10 frames a second?
TAMARA LACKEY: No.
AUDIENCE: Because
expressions move, right?
TAMARA LACKEY: Yeah.
I would say in a normal
portrait session.
A normal portrait session for me
lasts about two to three hours,
on average.
And that's building
in a lot of breaks
and letting the energy kind
of ebb and flow a little bit.
And in that time, I'm
probably capturing
a total of 300 images.
300 raw images.
And when I take that
back and cull them down,
I'm delivering about 60 images.
So the only time I do any
sort of burst shooting
is if I have someone
rapidly moving
or, you know, a kid
racing across the thing
or coming at me.
And I'm thinking
about, again, I'm
still thinking about
the technical aspects.
So I know that if I
have a subject who's
racing towards me, it's
significantly harder
to get a focused shot
of them than if they're
racing across the camera,
simply because of how
the technology works.
So if I do that, I
change my angle and say,
you run that way and
circle back to me.
And I might do a
burst mode, then.
But I'll still do still frame
by still frame of an individual,
because I feel I can
better measure it.
Better measure that expression.
AUDIENCE: How do
you keep your focus?
TAMARA LACKEY: Literally
the technical focal point?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
On your subjects?
Because I get these
moments, but then
I don't quite have the focus.
It's blurry.
TAMARA LACKEY: Yes.
So it's a very good
question about focus.
There's actually
about four steps
in a row I'm constantly
thinking about,
when I'm thinking about
literally getting focus.
Obviously, so much of this
talk is about emotionally
staying focused.
And for me, that's so important,
because you could take
two great shots like the ones I
showed you of that girl, frame
by frame next to each other,
and the one just feels off,
and the other one
feels so significant.
But technically, the
way I am achieving focus
is first of all, I
do single shot focus.
And I focus right on
the eyes every time.
Each and every time.
If I have a group, I focus
on the eyes of the person
most in the middle.
I watch my distance to subject.
I know that if I'm
photographing you from here,
I have a significantly
better shot at getting you
in focus at an F28
aperture than I
would if I were standing
right in front of you,
where I might get
one eye in focus.
Or if I'm leaning in toward
you with a micro lens,
and it's not going to
adapt the aperture for me.
I'm going to get an
eyelash in focus.
So keeping my distance from you
basically lets my focal plane
widen.
And I'll have more of a chance
of getting everything in focus.
And the closer I get to
you, the more that narrows,
and the less likely I am
to get things in focus.
So keeping distance
to subject is one.
Number two has to do with how
many people I'm photographing.
If I'm photographing a group,
like a family or organization,
or any sort of
collective of people,
I'm keeping in my
distance to subject.
And I'm also making sure I have
an extended field of focus.
And I'm keeping them on
the same focal plane.
So if I have five people,
I liken it to saying,
imagine there's a thin plane
of glass in front of you.
I want all of your noses
to be in the vicinity
of that plane of glass.
So I don't have to worry about
somebody a foot behind them
or a foot in front of them.
Either the person in the
foreground or the person
in the background
is going to be soft.
So thinking about that helps
significantly with focus,
is the focal plane.
And then lastly is going
to be my lens choice.
Certain lenses are always
going to be sharper for me
than others.
And then I pick
them accordingly.
Actually, I said lastly.
There's one more
thing, which has
to do with-- I hardly
ever tripod things.
I hardly ever do.
This is me using a
hand-held 105-28 lens.
And I'm shooting down.
And I'm shooting
relatively close.
But because I'm shooting
relatively close,
my aperture has
to be extended so
that I get more of
her face in focus.
Because of that, I
have to tripod myself.
Which is what I do a lot.
When I talk to you about
running with the little girl,
I'm keeping my
camera very steady.
I'm moving, but I'm keeping
my camera very steady.
So user error is another issue
that comes up for me a lot
with focus.
Is to make sure that I'm keeping
everything strong and in place.
AUDIENCE: So what
AF mode do you use?
Do you use single
shot or continuous?
TAMARA LACKEY: Yeah.
I use single shot nearly always.
I've recently been doing a
little bit more with the 3D
and the continuous on
the new Nikon cameras.
But even though they're
doing well for me,
I still am not sure of them.
AUDIENCE: And do you manually
select a focus point,
or do you just let the camera?
TAMARA LACKEY: Auto-focus.
Yeah.
So I shoot everything
in manual exposure.
So I'm constantly
using manual exposure,
which means I'm setting my
own aperture and shutter
speed and ISO.
But I'm always using the
auto-focus on the lens.
AUDIENCE: I mean, letting
the camera decide which
focus point to
use, what I meant.
TAMARA LACKEY: Single shot.
Auto-focus.
So I don't like the 45
focal points jumping up,
or the one bumping
around a million times.
This goes back to
what I'm trying
to achieve from
expression perspective.
If I feel like there's 45 red
focus dots that just came up
between me and you,
I can't see you.
I can't even look for what
the right expression is.
If I do single shot
focus and re-compose,
I can constantly keep
you right in front of me.
And I know what I'm
looking for with you.
And that no longer
is a distraction
between me being able
to achieve what I want.
AUDIENCE: I see.
So it's always the center point?
TAMARA LACKEY: Correct.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TAMARA LACKEY: Yes.
With a few exceptions.
One exception might be,
I have an experience
where I know I'm
photographing somebody
in the upper right hand
third of the image.
And they're going to be
zooming across the frame.
Then I might switch to the
joystick approach, where
I'll put the focal
point here so I
know I get them sharp as
they're moving through.
Because focusing
and re-composing
when they're moving and I'm
moving is a lot more difficult.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TAMARA LACKEY: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the adult portrait.
Once an adult has become
negative of the photograph.
Like he or she becomes
self-conscious of his or her
fitness.
If there are any
suggestions about how do you
smooth them or make them relax?
TAMARA LACKEY: So
what techniques
to help an adult relax?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like have
the photograph session
went smoothly.
TAMARA LACKEY: Yes.
That's a great question.
With adults, I find that the
name of the talk, Embracing
Self-Consciousness, it's
always going to be there.
The sooner I
embrace it, and what
I mean by that is literally
state, isn't this so weird?
I'm taking your picture.
You came to this place just so
I could get your photograph.
I will start by acknowledging
the discomfort in a situation.
And then what
happened over here,
what people naturally
do when you do that,
is they laugh self-consciously.
And the self-conscious laugh
is beautiful in a still frame.
It looks so raw and
honest and sweet.
It's a really lovely
image to capture.
And so even though someone might
feel a little uncomfortable,
or like look away a little
bit, kind of shy or awkward,
those looks in stills end up
being really strong images.
So even though that
person might not
feel like they're so comfortable
with the shoot you're getting,
as long as the frames look
good, that's what I care about.
So one of things I'll do is
I'll address the fact that this
is an awkward situation,
especially when we're
in front of other people.
There's a lot of times where
I'll do urban portraits,
or I'll do an editorial
portrait where
there's other people around.
And then it's just like
that self-consciousness
goes through the roof,
because not only am
I being photographed by you.
But all these people
are staring at me.
And this is so weird.
So by just taking into
account those factors
and addressing them, and even
playing with them a little bit,
like no one's watching, no one's
watching, no one's watching.
And then I'll click.
And so again, we're engaging.
And it's kind of you and
me against everybody else.
Like we're not going to
let them make fun of us,
we're going to do it ourselves.
That sort of thing ends
up engaging with them
in a way that just
meets them where
they are, in terms
of those feelings.
That goes a long way.
The amount of times I find
that in social situations,
people don't address
the weirdness that's
in front of them.
Why don't we just talk about it?
This is weird.
I find that just doing
that offers somebody
a sense of relief.
So one of the things
I wanted to do
is, first, to get
you guys all to agree
that you're all
seriously good-looking.
You do agree with that, right?
Good.
The other thing I wanted to do
was show a small animodo video
of some of these images
that I've been collecting,
outside of the ones
I just showed you,
for years that showcase a lot of
what I'm talking about when it
comes to self-consciousness
and expression.
This is actually
the song I'm going
to be using from
Triple Scoop Music,
was an original song
written by Tyler Stenson.
And it's called,
aptly, "We Grow."
So a couple minute slide show.
Hopefully this works OK.
[MUSIC - TYLER
STENSON, "WE GROW"]
TAMARA LACKEY:
Thank you very much.